[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of the severance finale the wee we are
this was directed by ben stiller and
written by creator dan erickson now
before i jump into my spoiler review
make sure to also check out my interview
with milchick himself trammell tillman
was a really good time we're talking all
about the finale and the season as a
whole it's spoilers so you should
definitely watch that after this
reviewer before i don't care but please
check it out so i am splitting this
review into three parts like we
literally see with the imagery in the
beginning of the episode where we see
mark helly and irving i'm going to start
with everything going on with helly then
we'll jump into irving and finish off
with mark so helly wakes up at the gala
so we've all been waiting for this all
season to see what's really going on
with the audi version of helly we
learned she is helena egan and a lot of
people obviously predicted she was negan
i was saying she definitely works at
lumen so i think everyone kind of knew
this was coming but it's still a great
reveal and exciting to see and i love
how they revealed it and that she's with
natalie and she's like you're on in 20.
so it's already developing tension
really well that she knows she has to
make a speech soon as audi heli and it's
just surreal watching the annie helly
seeing who she is on the outside the
horror of it all that you're realizing
you're the devil basically and isn't
this sci-fi at its best feeling the
shock of your character you've grown
attached to as we have now seeing who
she really is and knowing that she is
the daughter of the current ceo james
egan is really crazy because when i saw
that i went back and watched episode
three and you see that when she sees
this statue of jane helly literally does
a double take and they really keep it on
her face in reaction to that i love
little things like that it was such a
big hint that there was a connection
there so definitely check out that scene
again in episode three so this is also
the first time helena really was
supposed to meet the senator and gabby
and it's now heli meeting them and what
is crazy about this is the way gabby
talks about having three kids now and
she can't believe someone would even say
severance is a bad thing now what's
crazy about this is you're realizing
that gabby is using severance in the
sense of avoiding the pain of childbirth
and she's putting any gabby through that
and that's why any gabby had a different
name for the baby right that's what
devin had seen so it's cruel it's
another way the act of severance is
cruel on this other version of yourself
gabby's literally torching another
version of herself just like hell he is
and it's showing you how messed up this
can be and it's like you know justice
for any gabby here come on now you think
that the mdr department employees got it
bad think about for any gabby that she's
just experiencing the pain of childbirth
doesn't even get to name her child and
it keeps happening just awful and then
you see now that heli's seeing all the
photos on display of their department
and of her and it says helly a severed
story it really again speaks to how
these companies work that we see in life
today and like oh voted best place to
work and all these happy faces and
you're not seeing what's really going on
so that was just so powerful and really
effective and man you know shout out
milcheck he takes great photos gets
those great moments you know and i just
love this whole thing with her seeing it
it felt very westworld again just the
color palette of all the heli scenes
felt westworld but also the music and
the piano going on so i really like that
it's not a bad show to draw inspiration
from for sure well season one at least
and when we're seeing helena here
talking on the clip about growing up in
egan and having the nine principles read
to her at night before bed saying she
wasn't crazy about that but she's
learned to like embrace those principles
she's also saying that she wouldn't do
anything that she wouldn't do herself
and she's actually perfect person to say
that because she actually severs herself
and does what her workers do and she's
saying i don't think severance divides
us i think it brings us together just
this cringe stuff she's saying makes her
so unlikable but it is fascinating that
we're gonna learn more about helena and
how much she actually agrees with the
principles sure we see that on the
outside she is part of the machine but
there has to be something deep down that
was a little bit resistant to it because
it's coming out in her any version so
it's really fascinating too when helly
meets her audi's father jane egan the
current ceo and he's like are you still
in pain i cried in bed when they told me
what she tried to do to you talking
about you know helly herself and he's
like the grandfather would cherish what
you have done speaking of keir egan here
and shout out the actor of keir egan
mark geller he reached out to me
instagram he is a fan of the channel and
the reviews so really cool and i love
this line where he's like i remember i
brought home to you the first chip the
prototype blue and green lights you said
it's so pretty daddy everyone in the
whole world should get one and he's like
they will because of you they will all
be keir's children and that's what's
crazy is then after this helly looks
into the mirror and basically recites
like what you would see the act of
contrition you know in confession
basically that version of it for lumen
which we saw in the break room she's
reciting that apology again and i feel
like to her it's just a motivating tool
here self-motivation to get back at
these people for the torture she put her
through and you see natalie says to
helly here use the line how you see your
innie as your sister they'll love that
and natalie is just that classic
spokesperson for some corrupt
corporation like this right where she's
like you know with all transformative
technology there's some bumps in the
road yeah just little bumps right like
come on and you see when harmony shows
up here to helly and helly goes i'm
going to kill your company and that's
when harmony's like your company who the
hell do you think you are so you know
she can't talk down to helena but she
can sure talk down to helly and she's
like your friends will suffer mark will
suffer you'll be long gone but we'll
keep them alive in pain just awful stuff
here from harmony just really evil and
again even though she combats with the
company woman she always is a backer of
keir's values and i just love how heli
when she goes to make her speech enters
through a cube that has her face on it
and it opens up showing the severance
there nice touch production designers
and she's saying to the whole crowd you
know i'm actually an innie i'm helly r
everything we told you about severance
is a lie we're not happy we're miserable
so natalie's face drops completely and
she's like they torture us down there
we're prisoners and this is where
actually natalie's the one who tackles
her off the stage exactly edited
perfectly between milicic tackling dylan
i really like that and that's where
we're going to kind of leave off where
helly is going to be triggered back into
helena next season so really cool stuff
with the heli storyline i think i
enjoyed that the most in this episode it
was just surreal to see this whole gala
going on and learning more about helena
and her ways in real life and you know
how much she's behind all of this and
like i said it's just brilliant sci-fi
to see hely being the one who's learning
all this about herself outside so we'll
jump now to irving right irving sees all
his paintings these black paintings that
we know with the black paint that he has
visions of at work and ace of spades is
playing and he meets his dog radar but
we also see is there's navy metals hung
up on the wall and i'm assuming they're
his but they could all just be his
father's so we're not totally sure he's
in the navy but i'm gonna guess he is
like his dad was and he finds a trunk
with his dad's navy uniform a picture of
him but where it gets really interesting
is under that he's clearly hiding
blueprints of lumen and a severed
employees list and what's important
about that is that he has notes on this
list that says things like tried to make
contact or divorce no kids and he's like
who else is 58 and he also has on this
map of the town of kier he marks
locations of employees on that list so
to me irving either was someone
investigating lumen who wanted to go
into the inside of this or he was
someone who was like mark getting intel
that something was off what was
happening to him in general at lumen and
he was going and finding out what's
going on he's clearly hiding it because
he's still in this area of cure but
you're also seeing too he has an article
of a severed worker named dalton emery
who is suing lumen for injury and he
said that on the way home from work his
left hand begun to throb violently it
says in the article we have seen this
happen with mark mark looks at his hand
and it starts shaking and what's crazy
is former employee dalton is saying that
it cut off his sensations in his hand
that would just be like turning on an
elevator he can't feel it so this is
fascinating and it's showing you there's
graver consequences like what happened
to pd with the side effects of severance
and that mark is starting to already
experience him it's only going to get
worse now what he's looking for on this
map is bert right and where he lives and
all this to go see him and it's so great
and fascinating again there's stuff they
can do with theonies and the audis and
what happens when irving's and he's in
the real world again that's the real
feeling like he's a kid because he
doesn't know how to drive a car and what
really goes on with that so it's a great
job by john chatturo showing that in his
face and i like that his license plate
has a little picture of keir on it and
yeah it's just so funny it's like crazy
watching him trying to figure out how to
just drive but what's crazy is when he
gets to bert's he sees he's with another
man and he goes to slam the door but
what's the good news of this is that
bert is alive he wasn't just killed when
he retired that could still happen maybe
that's why he's screaming on the door to
warn him but we'll see it's a great
point to leave off with irving so where
the true suspense of this episode
happens is with mark's story because he
is literally with harmony so when he's
snapping back into any mark he's getting
slapped in the face with seeing it's
miss cobell at the party for some reason
he's learning that he has a sister who
he first thinks is his wife because he
makes a comment about the baby which i
thought was great and he's like how's
our baby and i love we get to meet rick
and sister rebecc not rebecca and she
says a lion i have sores on the back of
my head for my bird you might see them
so funny like everything with rick and
is great and now he gets introduced to a
sister who's just as funny and i love
that rick and just has literally
paintings of himself in his house just
hysterical and we see rickon as other
books on the table the only title really
get a glimpse of is dr rickens wisdom so
i'd love to hear about more of these
books he's written but i love that annie
mark is like a fanboy of rickon that
this guy's like an idol to him right
this book saved his life in lumen so
it's fascinating to see him literally go
up like a fan to him when he literally
says mr hale um rickon like literally
first approaching him like this hero to
him i i thought that was great and it's
shocking to ricken because it's such a
great contrast to audi mark who doesn't
take ricken's whole stick seriously but
any mark loves it and i love the line
ricken has here he's like i don't know
my voice gets like that i sound like a
sad old hamburger waiter i just laughed
out loud at that man he he's gold and we
see now there's all the suspense through
the scenes with mark because he's trying
to have the talk with devin keeps
getting distracted he's trying to see
through rick and more information and he
was about to show a picture of gemma
doesn't happen yet that he sees a
picture but it will but again it's all
just adds to great suspense in these
scenes and again having harmony there
and i love the line where she's like
when you hugged me you suddenly became
tense and then he says he'll be right
back to her and he says thanks miss
cobell so this was his huge mess up here
and that's when she figures it all out
she was already on to it but this
confirms it so that just adds to this
crazy suspense where the crazy fast
piano is playing cobell's flying to the
gala here calling mill check telling
milk check what's going on and milkshake
literally books it to the security
office this was so intense and he's
trying to cut through the tie here that
is on the door and dylan and him have a
great moment here again with some humor
they always sneak in which is so great
where he's like i bet the tempers were
disappointed talking about the tempers
that were dancing in the waffle party
he's like i can get you any perk you
want dylan paintball and coffee cozy so
it's just crazy to hear that they even
have lumen paintball but zac cherry
really kills it here saying the line i
want to remember my effing kid being
born but this is huge because then
milchik says you have two others i can
tell you about them which is just sad
and crazy and again really great
performances from the both of them here
and we'll see that male chicks want to
tackle dylan and causes everything to
snap back now i like this moment too
that mark does get to tell devin about
lumen and to send inspectors but she has
a great idea to actually have
journalists be the ones they tell
because you know even the police are
being corrupt with lumen here but i like
they got the information here where mark
says i just want to know why he put me
in there and she explains that he lost
his wife this was sad touching and
surreal and it was cool to see this it
felt so different for television like
this kind of situation which is exciting
and getting to tell him that his wife is
wonderful gemma and that he didn't want
to experience the pain of losing her so
what's great about this finale is
there's so much information learned by
our characters and instead of producing
a bunch of questions that can frustrate
people this finale answers a lot of
things for us but also it gets so much
information to our main characters
they're literally learning about the
outside world so it's gonna be
interesting it moves a plot along in
that sense to set up for season two that
could just be even crazier with them
having this info now now again they
always just throw in little humor in the
show it's so subtle but it's brilliant i
love that the guy at the party's the one
who finds the baby and for some reason
when he finds it he just wants to take
all the credit he's like devin i found
your child i'm the one who found her
like that was just again in such a tense
serious moment this you know subtle
humor happening in the background i
thought that was great and that will
lead to now any mark finds a wedding
photo of him and gemma who to him is
miss casey and it leaves with this great
cliffhanger where he runs in he's like
she's live talking about gemma and
that's right where he snaps back so this
cliffhanger is the complete opposite of
the cliffhanger from the penultimate
episode where it's reversed so they're
going to snap back to their audis to
lead into season two so it also leaves a
door to like they could kind of open
season two maybe a new character
different situation a little bit of a
time jump and then go back to where we
left off there's so many things they can
do here with this information being
learned i really hope ben stiller and
dan erickson have a good outline of
where this is going to go so it doesn't
get lost because this is such a big idea
they're tackling it's brilliant i just
hope there is an end game for this and
doesn't frustrate people in the end and
that they feel disappointed but right
now it's hitting it out of the park and
i have faith they do have a plan i'm
excited to see what they bring for
season two so i am giving this finale a
9.8 it was the best episode of the
season to me for sure the only thing i
would say it kind of sucks it was only
41 minutes and the last two episodes are
both you know 41 minutes and the other
one was 43. you know there is a part of
me that wishes maybe they should have
just made the finale one long episode
combining those two but again if they
did maybe there wouldn't be as much
suspense as there was by having it
separate so again i think it was a
really solid finale i think it just
closed up this season really well and
made you excited for season two while
giving you enough answers to feel
satisfied but leaving you excited for
what's to come so let me know you
thought down below and please please
make sure to check out my interview with
mel tillman who plays mill check we talk
all about what just happened in the
whole season as a whole and please
follow me at steve arley's show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and please subscribe because i do
other shows movie reviews as well and i
also do interviews and it really helps
me in so many ways you have no idea i
appreciate all you guys i enjoyed
watching this season with you so i'd
love to keep the conversation going down
below and let me know where you think
season two might go and again what you
would rate this finale until next time
i'll see you later
i love you
[Music]